welcome to hari sadhus the Chinna where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into newest tech products recently
there have been many deals on first
generation rising CPUs and motherboards
and today we're taking a look at why
this is possibly one of the best times
to buy a rise in CPU but before we delve
into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this every
single day
rice and two just came out very recently
and as a result retailers are wanting to
get rid of their original rise in CPU
stock rise and two does offer more
performance than the original rise in
series but the original rise in series
is definitely still the value King the
performance per dollar that's the
original rising series offers are just
unbeatable for example right now you can
get the rise in seven seven hundred
which is an 8 core 16 thread CPU with a
really good stock puller for just two
hundred and twenty dollars you won't
find that anywhere else
that's literally cheaper than the i-5
series from Intel and that doesn't even
have eight course without hyper
threading on top of that it comes with a
really crappy stock cooler if it comes
with one at all overall I really just
think there isin 7 1700 do being offered
right now it's absolutely insane and it
could go out of stock at any point so if
you guys are interested and I really
recommend that you guys don't hesitate
on buying the CPU please it really is a
great deal bison to isn't just leading
to price reductions in the original
Rison series it's actually also leading
to price cuts in the corresponding
motherboards for example most original
rise in series motherboards are price
cut by twenty to forty dollars right now
and you can find high-end b250
motherboards for about twenty to thirty
dollars cheaper and at about a hundred
dollars you can find lower end beauty
fifty boards for easily at sixty seven
dollars so there really is a great value
being offered there as well well what
about X 370 motherboards well if you're
considering to buy an original series
rise and CPU for the performance that
offers per dollar
then just don't even think about the X
370 series but it's really just a
premium product for
price and there's really no reason to
buy it and it doesn't really offer
anything over be 350 motherboards except
for SLI and that really doesn't matter
and if you're going for value then
buying an x3 71 that boy just doesn't
make sense at all I mean if you're
willing to spend some extra cash you
might as well put that money into 2700 X
which will actually give you more
performance unlike the motherboard and
what does 2700 X of X 370 motherboard it
may actually make sense but with an
original series rise in CPU just don't
even think about it
also there are no CPUs that are coming
out very soon that's going to beat the
value that the Rison 7 1700 is offering
right now right now you know the
performance of all the CPUs out on the
market right now and there are plenty of
benchmark and performance videos on
YouTube and other websites so there
really is no reason to skimp out on
research it's really easy to make an
educated decision at this point I know
that the Rison 5 and resin 3 for the
rise in two series haven't come out yet
but considering what price the Rison 7
1700 is being offered for right now I'm
not sure why you would even go for those
I see words rising 3 and rising 5 series
shine like in the budget market but if
you're willing to buy a rising 5 then I
really recommend you guys consider
spending a little bit more money and
getting the rise in 7 1700 right now but
I really don't want you guys to miss out
on this great deal like for example if
you're considering to buy the 1600 X
then you should definitely just go ahead
and buy the 1700 because first of all
the 1600 X doesn't have a stock cooler
so you can save money there and plus
you're saving money on the motherboard
region anyways so it's definitely worth
the upgrade the only other chips that
are coming out this year is in toast
next series and the 9700 K may have a
great performance
it may even have eight cores and 16
threads and be able to overclock all the
way to 5 gigahertz with no problem well
at the same time it'll definitely cost
over 350 dollars and it's corresponding
motherboards will definitely cost over
150 dollars as well so as a result the
combination would cost at least $500 but
with the rise in seven combination right
now you can
for $300 which song was half the price
now does that mean that you should not
buy a 9700 K or any high-level CPU of
course not that's definitely not what
I'm suggesting but if you're going for
value for the dollar then this is
definitely where the value is right now
on top of this I don't think the rise in
7 1700 is going to drop any further in
price it's already being offered at a
really steep discount and I really doubt
it's gonna drop more it may drop in
under 10 to 20 dollars but even that is
really quite unlikely
so overall Rison has been offering great
value from the very beginning and I
think that this is the best value that
it is going to be able to offer to the
consumers so overall new Rison CPUs have
come out and as a result original series
Rison CPUs and their corresponding
motherboards have seen crazy price cuts
and as a result they're being offered at
really good prices right now the best of
these deals is definitely the horizon 7
1700 which is an octa-core processor
with 16 threads and a really good stock
fuller for a little over $200 there
aren't any CPUs that are coming out soon
or exist right now that are going to
beat the battery that the 1700 is
offering any time soon on top of that
the 1700 is most likely not gonna drop
any more in price this is the best time
to buy dries in seven seven two hundred
and so please don't miss out on this
great opportunity therefore if you guys
are considering to buy a risin 5 arisin
7 CPU and really care about value then
the horizon 7 1700 with the be 350
motherboard is definitely the way to go
so what do you guys think are you guys
angry that Intel has been over pricing
their CPUs for so long and they have
been ripping off all of us or are you
just happy that AMD is finally bringing
some competition make sure to post down
in the comments below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
but that's what I have for you guys this
time if you guys like this video then
make sure to drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you would like to
see more videos just like this every
single day but until next time
by
[Music]